hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer flat world
of sports pack in minecraft du also flap
ebay gibt es jetzt auch für minecraft
ich habe gedacht das erste video was sie
dort gemacht habt ihr ganz witzig
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich mach
es nicht nochmal auf dem handy war ich
habe die npd installiert weil ich kenne
alle die über facebook folgen also die
man meiner facebook seite manchmal
vorbeigucken wissen dass ich ein video
gepostet habe wo ein typ sein handy
zerstört hat der handy weil der fed
bleibt irgendwie gestürzt ist also
wirklich richtig zur sache werden wegen
diesem spiel gemacht aber darum geht es
nicht sondern es geht um kräfte kräfte
des youtube kanal bzw
minecraft die immer mal so minecraft
maps machen und wir sehen schon jeder
sind ein paar röhren da sie mir vogel
was könnte denn wohl fühle webseiten ist
es eine vierten birdman ihr seht schon
wenn ich jetzt hinweg fliegen will oder
so ich werde zurückgebaut auch wenn ich
hier nach oben fliegen will
ich werde zurückgebaut und wir haben
hier als verschiedene
auswahlmöglichkeiten erst mal findet
download zudem app instagram alles
findet in der beschreibung und na ja gut
ich würde sagen ich zeige euch das mal
ganz kurz ins wackeln wir erstmalig auch
random noise level klicken
das zeige ich euch am ende am besten
erstmal zeige ich mal hier difficulty
sie sondern können das ganze auf medium
stellen dann ist erstmal erst mal vater
ist das ein bisschen anders sind die
torheit höher und weiter auseinander und
so was alles und die teile sind näher
zusammen dann gibt es noch medium und
gibt nach
und immer wenn man so etwas macht dann
kann man randy neville klicken und dann
seht ihr dass sich jeder so am rand bin
und dann seht ihr schon dass diese
ganzen rühren die da quasi vorhanden
sind die verändert sich jetzt alle so
ein bisschen also das ganze wird jetzt
wenn ihr zb mal auf falls sie nicht ich
kann nicht mit meiner hand
hier gucken doch hier zum beispiel wenn
sie auf eine röhre guckt jetzt hier
jetzt ist sie auf einmal oben ins ziel
da unten also das wird das ganze wird
gerade randomized randomized zu deutsch
übersetzt so zufällig gemacht also es
kommt jetzt ein zufälliges level ist
auch bei flirt immer so dass jedes level
ist anders nicht nächstes das gleiche
level genauso wie bei doodle jump oder
irgendwas
an irgendwelche anderen spiele und das
hat sich jetzt quasi verändert das erste
tor sitzt da oben wollen das ja relativ
mittig eigentlich so dann würde ich
sagen ich lasse es nur auf dem 14
wenn ihr irgendwie mehr schafft das
ganze geht es 50 also es geht nur bis 50
lambert an sich ist ja unendlich mehr
oder weniger also 999 1000 oder so gibt
es hieß es dass sie geht bis 50 auch ich
hab grad schon gestartet jetzt bin ich
runter gefallen also wenn ihr unter
falscher flagge aus happy birthday und
angefangen die stars und zwar ist es
halt so bei der bei der handy app dass
es unendlich ist hier geht's bis 50
denkt aber nicht bis 50 vorbei sondern
könnt ja noch auf hartz stendorf medium
also wenn ihr auf fahrt bis 50 schafft
könnt ihr einfach mal links runter
posten ins video und dann das dass er
das geschafft hat oder allgemein könnte
mir noch euren highscore schreiben und
jetzt nicht höre ich habe zehn millionen
oder sogar das schreibt der krieg von
meer und wetter eine backpfeife ich
würde sagen wir fangen an witz dann ja
ich habe schon drei minuten geredet so
start games jetzt kommen wir zur
steuerung die steuerung ist sehr sehr
kompliziert und zwar erstmalig schwebe
ich jetzt ein bisschen über dem boden
das sieht man nicht aber ich bin über
boden weil wenn ich hier auftreten würde
du bist hier seht dass ich kann hier
fliegen
die steuerung ist so und zwar ja es ist
echt blöd zu erklären und zwar muss man
nicht einfach es war richtig einfach
wenn man einfach space drücken müsste
damit man springt sondern man ist quasi
im creative mode und man muss pace
gedrückt halten dann geht man auf eine
höhe
so zum beispiel und dann wieder runter
fällt muss man doppelt space zurück und
dann gedrückt halten also tecdax sodann
gedrückt halten gehen wir wieder hoch
und wieder runter ich mache jetzt mal
vor und zwar wenn ich hier bin so dann
falle ich runter ist als doppel space
geduld ist nicht auf der höhe
jetzt kann ich hier acht jetzt bin ich
abgestützt das werde ich jetzt nicht so
gut machen hat man noch mal so und zwar
just a game klicken statt game
so so zac ab durch hier
darunter so jetzt auf die wir jetzt hier
durch jetzt hierdurch und ihr denkt so
höhe das ist ja voll einfachen macht
erstmal nach das denken die meisten auch
immer bei flat wenn sie die app dann
sehen
ich habe sechs geschafft 26 ich versuche
mal über 10 zu kommen das wäre schon
killer irgendwie über zehn mir schon
geil ich hoffe überhaupt ihr habt ton
weil man minecraft ich mich schon die
ganze zeit rum spart bei diesem neuen
snapshot also braucht halt den
allerneuesten snapshot dafür gut das war
knapp
auf die höhe hier kommen noch mal
kompliziert das blöd wenn das so hoch
oben ist das erste tor so hier locker
easy durch hier auch locker easy darauf
locker easy
ozzy
okay sie 66 ist mein highscore bisher
ihr seht auch rechts ist eine coole
score anzeige die euch so ich geh jetzt
mal auf diese hier
was man speedrun hier
ab
auf die höhe jetzt durch das ich denke
wenn man sich mit dieser materie hier so
ein bisschen das man kann natürlich auch
shift drücken es ist natürlich einfacher
will ich sagen als flexibler toffen
mobile device anhalt noch mit schiff die
möglicher darunter zu gehen und sich
zeit lassen kann und bei happy bird an
sich ist es ja auf dem handy so dass man
das ganze
man ist ja quasi immer in bewegung
geradeaus in die er nach nach vorne halt
also nie irgendwie ihr wisst was meinen
dass man irgendjemanden zurück kann oder
so dass ich mir zeit lassen kann es
besteht toren
das ist die der verletzten bei der kg
hier so 8
9 verdammt aber ich habe zehn geschafft
meine damen und herren ich habe zehn
geschäft so und ich würde sagen wir
lassen das jetzt mal dabei weil ich
finde es wird kann man noch nie so lange
spielen
dass ich jetzt in 20 minuten video
ausmachen kann ich mache jetzt mal eben
noch die ganze schaltung kaputt ich
sprenge die map jetzt einfach mal auch
in die luft kommt dass man gleich noch
ich würde sagen wenn es euch gefallen
hat meine lieben freunde also sieht die
ganze schaltung hier aus ob ich kann ja
gar nicht durchgehen also ich hoffe mal
dass ich jetzt hier durchspielen kann
ich das ganze erst einmal kaputt mache
der stars hallo ich kann ich will immer
wieder dahin zurück gefordert das echt
komisch wenn ihr lieben freunde wenn
euch gefallen hat lassen bewährt und da
wenn ihr eventuell noch mal so eine flat
world video haben wollte und sonst wenn
ich fragen hero kommt nachher noch und
das geheimnisvolle geräusche hatten wir
ja beim letzten mal waren die hat man da
beim letzten mal habe ich das überhaupt
alle ausgesucht habe ich habe ein neues
tolles geheimnisvolles geräusch für euch
und zwar sagt mir doch mal was das hier
für ein geräusch ist schreibt begann
schreibt mir die kommentare wenn ihr
wisst dass das für ein geräusch hatte
was das für ein geräusch was ist es für
ein geräusch schreibt wir in die
kommentare wir sind beim nächsten mal
wieder ihren wunderschönen tag viel spaß
darüber hero und